22 de octubre y es momento de hablar de
economía y para ello recibo con
muchísimo gusto a la especialista daniel
hablando un ramírez
daniela muy buenas noches méxico y eeuu
evitaron entrar en un conflicto
diplomático por el agua a las muy buenas
noches mire hay un tratado que data de
1944 que obliga a cada uno a entregarle
cierta cantidad del preciado líquido al
otro como compensación por los ríos que
comparten en la zona fronteriza
eeuu debe entregarle a méxico más de 9
mil millones de metros cúbicos porque
ingenio desde el río colorado y en
contraparte méxico le entrega más de 2
mil o sea menos de una cuarta parte de
lo que recibe pero por la sequía los
agricultores mexicanos en especial del
estado fronterizo de chihuahua no están
dejando extraer el recurso y
protagonizaron protestas finalmente se
llegó a un acuerdo con el que eeuu podrá
disponer de agua para consumo humano
pero con un compromiso escuchemos cuáles
de que si necesitamos el agua para el
consumo humano
ellos van
a proporcionarla
y que si tenemos una situación de sequía
severa también seguimos en el norte del
continente daniela en estados unidos
específicamente ya se aprobó el uso del
red de civil para tratar el kobe 19
cuánto costará mírate se convierte en el
único tratamiento que tiene autorización
plena de la agencia de alimentos y
medicamentos para tratar la infección
causada por el virus y que fue usado por
trump recordemos su fabricante es la
estadounidense jill is the science y
venderá este antiviral bajo la marca del
mar y su costo es de 3 mil 120 dólares
para un tratamiento de cinco días pero
si el comprador es gubernamental como
por ejemplo el departamento de asuntos
de veteranos el costo será menor de unos
2.340 dólares esta farmacéutica espera
fabricar este año más de dos mil
millones más de dos millones de dosis y
triplicar esa producción en 2021 el
público en general pues tendrá esos tres
mil 120 dólares como ya lo dijimos bueno
se acaba y es que denuncia perdida
récord de este año pero no es por la
crisis de coronavirus es por el embargo
de eeuu sí señor dice que las sanciones
de la casa blanca le han costado el país
165 mil 570 millones de dólares este año
marcando un récord histórico así lo
señala el gobierno en un informe que
presenta cada cuatro años ante naciones
unidas
washington ha endurecido su bloqueo a la
isla al punto que sus ciudadanos no
pueden hospedarse en los hoteles
estatales que son casi todos ni llevar
ciertos productos de vuelta a su país
los daños acumulados durante casi seis
décadas alcanzan a precios corrientes la
cifra descomunal de 144 mil 413 millones
de dólares
daniela uber se va de otros dos países
de américa latina bueno esta
multinacional perdió 4 mil 700 millones
de dólares en el primer semestre de este
año esto hizo que la empresa anunciara
hoy que su plataforma über
its
se despide de argentina y de colombia
desde finales de noviembre über es una
de las principales representantes de la
llamada economía colaborativa junto con
el bien vi pero como sabemos ha visto
como su actividad principal que es el
transporte de pasajeros se desplomó
durante los peores meses de la pandemia
por eso ha recurrido a servicios
alternativos como la entrega de comida o
de mercancías para tratar de amortiguar
este golpe sin embargo debe priorizar
los países que les son más rentables y
colombia y argentina no están dentro de
ellos claro vamos con los indicadores
económicos del día wall street del cerro
con ganancias moderadas tras conocerse
que las peticiones de subsidios por
desempleo cayeron a su nivel más bajo
desde marzo en europa predominó el rojo
hoy salvo londres el resto de bolsas se
siguió perdiendo por cuenta del aumento
de casos de coronavirus y en américa
latina' cuarta jornada consecutiva de
ganancias para la bolsa de sao paulo
cerramos con la cifra del día
usted sabe cuantos millonarios hay en el
mundo en lo mínimo tengo leída yo le
tengo esa cifra son 51
millones de millonarios según un informe
del segundo banco más grande de suiza
que es el credit suisse ellos son los
que tienen un patrimonio superior a un
millón de dólares quiénes amasan una
fortuna de más de 50 millones de dólares
son los súper millonarios estos en el
mundo son 175 mil seiscientos el dato
que le tengo decir es que el 1% de la
población adulta mundial tiene el 43 por
ciento de toda la riqueza y los más
afortunados como vemos son estados
unidos china y japón- muy bien daniela
pues muchas gracias por tu millonaria
información y ustedes muchas gracias por
su compañía ya lo sabe vea más mucho más
en francés 24
[Música]